Over time, the amount of energy humans use has increased.
This is happening because there are more and more people that need energy...
...to power their cars, TVs and lots of other stuff.
The energy sources we use emit gases called greenhouse gases.
Like a greenhouse traps heat to keep plants warm,...
...greenhouse gases trap heat from the sun to keep us warm.
Too much of this can cause the Earth some big problems.
When the sun heats the Earth,....
....that heat is trapped in greenhouse gases, which are in the atmosphere.
These greenhouse gases keep the Earth warm.
But too many of them and the Earth can't cool.
You might ask, "Can we fix it?" or "Can we help?"
Yes, you can.
Make sure to recycle and just do all around good environmental things for the Earth.